this sequence is called building the  silo we put in the movie trying to kind  of solidify that relationship with Papa  and Arlo we thought wouldn't it be great  if they started building something  together the analogy that we would use  was like if you were building a car with  your dad and so building the silo was  something very important on the farm and  we could also show some of our Lowe's  characteristics something that I really  loved about the scene is that  relationship with dad but we were trying  to really focus on Arlo and this montage  was really about incapability and that  he was weak and it just didn't take us  very far in terms of our Lowe's journey  so that's why this sequence was cut out  of the film  this looks like a good spot  Arlo you're gonna help me build a silo  stand back papa  will I be like you someday you'll be me  and more